when nature turns this kind the migrants
take their chances
warm weather calm seas mean more boats
and more people desperate enough to do
this to enter the country
scenes like this are played out if not
every day than several times a week
right now
here we filmed the border force vessel
vigilant taking on board dozens of
migrants from three separate small boats
once on board they know they are safe
and they know an asylum process will
begin
they will have paid thousands of pounds
to smuggling gangs to make this illegal
journey for some it will pay off for
others it won't
their journey is difficult
stopping them taking the risk even more
so
the big question of course is how to
stop this happening how to persuade the
french authorities to do more how to
tackle the smuggling gangs and how to
deter the migrants from taking this
dangerous route many believe the latest
plan
to turn boats around at sea effectively
should not be part of the solution
but it may soon be the way things are
done in these waters if it is practical
and safe to do so
quite how that can be determined in the
world's busiest shipping lane is yet to
be fully explained
on the french side of the channel today
the maritime police did little to stop
the crossings despite pressure and money
from the uk to do so
this human crisis is a political one too
and the end of summer will not mean
problem solved
mark austin sky news
over the channel